first of all method man such a fantastic
name such a great name and you consider
that your stage name
yes but do people in real life
when you go to the bank and you say yeah
i want to get
i want to you know do this transaction
do they say yes
method man is that what they say i want
i want that to be true
i want that i i go to a couple of
different branches the the
the really cool branch that i go to
that's in my close to my old
neighborhood they call me method man
very cool but the person that i've been
going to since i've opened my account
this lady named laurie at citibank
yeah she'd known me for over 18 years so
she has every right to call me cliff
okay all right she can do that that
she's on the right yes
you've got such great nicknames johnny
blaze
yeah that's one of them i wanted it is
italian
that's fantastic you know uh
staten island's finest uh uh
[Music]
nickels tell me about hotness vehicles
okay that was just a silly name that i
came up with
and uh it was supposed to represent like
hot loaded nickel nine millimeter
bullets
yeah but you see how i went crazy with
it and
it turned into hot nixon because i had
this big
nixon thing going on and stuff and i
just liked the way nixon talked he was
crooked as well but
i just like the way it talks i am not a
crook
you know what first of all uh you're
that's the first nixon impression
anyone's busted out on this show
in maybe forever that's fantastic and it
was very good
you know what i love there's a wu-tang
name generator
online and you can put your own name
in your real name and then it tells you
what your wu tang name
would be have you tried it you know what
i did it
i did it and my nickname my wu-tang name
when i put in conan o'brien is
thunderous observer
now that's dope that's good right that's
that's dope i i like that a lot i like
that a lot
myself when i put my name in it came up
method man believe it or not
but then i did it a couple of more times
after that and it was some crazy
throat wizard or some some something
weird like that you know everything is
wizard
i i've ran into a lot of people and you
know they they get wizard at the end of
the name or whatever i guess it's the
smith thing
i don't know i don't know i don't know
all i know is you're talking to
thunderous observer i love that i love
that
it goes with the o'brien thing so you
know yeah i think i could slide right
into wooten
no one would know conan the thunderous
observer
o'brien i mean we might as well put a
microphone in your hand and put you
right on stage
right now yeah yeah and people would
throw
batteries at me
hard they would really whip batteries at
me hard